all right for people who are joining
this live stream we are talking about a
fairly simple function text normalize um
[Music]
okay so let's take a look at what's
going on here so I don't know stand
explain to me these various forms so
these are like different zoo is yes I
understand that but what why would one
use them and how do they relate to
machine learning models or anything else
so that standard right and and some
machine model uses them as
pre-processing for example the birds
multi-language uses them as reprocessing
so we need them to import the bird
multi-language to our system which would
be great because it might help us do
things like 2x cases in many languages
we might help everyone doing machine
learning models with many long terms all
right okay so what's the default
if if we I mean what
the difference between these forms let's
take a look at what
what what what are these different I
mean if I look at these different forms
so I take this thing here and I simply
look um well you've got you've got some
examples here but but I mean this was
just no these were just when we're
designing the arguments and so on so I
think ok so let's take your example here
and let's see what it does
oops
all of that okay
okay so where as what am I seeing with
them NFC for example I really hope we're
fixing them okay well can we describe a
little bit what these things actually do
can you tell me what they actually do
do you have an idea yeah so like I can
just dis do you want me to just look it
up so in like first they would do I
could like technically they say that
they would first decompose that is what
NFD is doing and then NFC will compose
back using certain rules which is so we
need to know a little bit more what the
actual description of what these things
are doing is I can send the Wikipedia
page and no I want to see the I want to
see the thing from the standard from I
can send that I already have it here
you
okay
you
okay so we need to understand what this
is doing so
this is turning a ring
into something with the explicit
diacritical mark right in this case
well canonical
composition and then si will compose it
back so what's the difference between
the character 0 0 c5
standees
type of tear critiques and kind of I
assume it's going to decompose and
canonical eyes every single thing right
but the point is that that okay so these
are canonical versions of characters
that look the same right so we've
already addressed a bunch of this in
Wolfram Alpha and it will be interesting
to understand what
okay
to i-75
okay
as done so I mean there's perfectly
sensible but but it's just um
you
okay okay I understand that's
interesting that that it's interesting
so the thing that is most directly
related to as you say is removed our
critics
which we sort of including as one of the
possible form that's that's all question
like should we extend text normalize and
making something bigger or we keep it to
this Unicode thing and then we could
know I should make it bigger I think we
should be able to normalize it in
different ways I mean this is character
by character well it's more or less
because it could also be called Unicode
normalize and be you know more low-level
function that just does this five
Unicode stand our transformation being
one way to go as well if we don't want
to overdo function well I think it'd be
better to call it character normalize
because that's what it's doing here
except that it isn't quite because it's
got the is it the case that there are
versions in which you know for 103 Oh a
is being turned into
is is that is there a transformation
that goes from NFD to NFC or is it
character normal eyes
which is a completely different you know
so character normalize would be just
taking individual so does it ever it
does it ever make the [ __ ] string
shorter yes yes when I mean let's take a
look at what it does so let's look at
let's look at it example you just give
an example here like the turkey its
bigger with n fkd know it expanded it
with n fkd there's no evidence law to I
see that it okay so let's take a ring
okay and let's say text normalize so if
I understand correctly an FD should turn
this into the character followed by its
diacritic
you
yep okay so now if
say texts normalize of that NFC I don't
think it's gonna do anything it is so
I'm wrong okay
hmm but this is really character level
normalization
I mean that's interesting that
transformation
okay so let's do
one is six-nine as that s thingy so
let's say we say text normalized so the
prediction would be the text normalized
and FD will give have to diacritics cell
I'm a right okay by the way those are
the examples you should give
no that's
it's much easier to understand since
most people don't know Korean um
right so and what you should start off
with is I would say I think the example
they give which is capital a ring
okay I am writing notes oh here I'll put
them in um
yeah I mean this is not useful I mean
it's just like like we got to explain
what's going on otherwise people just
don't have a have a chance um okay so
this will be text normal eyes or
character normal eyes and then this is
an F D and then text normal eyes
of that as well retype the string
NFC as that now and let's just see
whether that's actually the same as yeah
that's the same I know it's in that
range so we also want to show I mean
some of these other things that they
talk about here like like for example
I'm sure if we do text normalize of such
double struck
oh I should done the capital well anyway
okay so do that to NF D now if I'm
understanding correctly that we'll just
throw away the double struck nurse but
it didn't so if you do an ad that should
throw away the double struck miss I
think so
and if KD okay
you
while you're wrong Oh No so like it
shows like LG like there's examples
later let's find out what this maybe
this is in private Unicode space let's
take a look at where this is and if it
is by the way you should make that make
sure that's in the the possible issues
it's things in private Unicode space
aren't going the other that's in private
Unicode space okay okay so whatever the
that um okay so this I mean this is a
very special case of Hangul being
decomposable isn't it if I pick a random
Chinese character it will absolutely not
be decomposable yes
so let's compare with what we say when
we say removed our critics
I think this should be called character
normalize because that's kind of what
it's doing I mean text normalization
could be something much more elaborate
not certain about this but I think
um
let's think about this for a second okay
so what do you have any comments on the
idea of calling this character normalize
so if you see it character normalize
then we can just have the Unicode forms
like tilde n FK CK's fold and leave out
the diacritic list lower case and upper
case because we thank you so yeah I
would think so because just repeats of
other things we already have yes I mean
this is a more technical function that
is um
so I'm Oh give it character normalize if
only the first like phew yeah I must and
I understand um Carl our live stream is
asking what does this do to an emoji um
can we type in there we can we can
certainly make a character code that is
in let's see if we say I don't know how
well it would displays in the front end
yet I'm from character code of um let's
see what what would be a let's try that
oh this not that many 1 million okay
sorry let's try the 1 million character
code okay so that was but let's do now
this some text normalize because that
should have a correct form internally
even though it's not displaying yet
brilliant an error of unspecified nature
occurred that's an that's bizarre I've
never seen that before that's kind of
wild um
to code
Wow
okay so that needs to be reported
whatever that did that's just totally
weird that's totally weird to display
that other problem
I have never seen that before that is
that is the wildest thing I mean that's
the because those are within Unicode
range I mean those are within within our
existing Unicode range
well okay let's find out what it is I
mean that may be a nun
amazing
far out
yeah okay um
you
you
you
yeah I think this is the right thing
character normalizes the right thing
happens if we say um whether we know
what the character name is for that
okay mystery is all around Wow
well you need to ask the people in the
front end group what is going on with
this this is very odd I'm and we could
look up the Unicode character elsewhere
really odd that's really odd what is in
that part of Unicode space
let's just try random thing there yeah
Wow been on our live stream saying the
same hair has been coming up when you
import Twitter text that's really weird
that's really weird because this was
this was all working and we could try it
in 12 hour but I think it'll be that's
it but I wonder what that is
5 6 208 um let's go look in the Unicode
standard
you
um
hopefully we can just look up in here
adopter character what is that
oh goodness sake huh interesting
okay okay they're selling emoji I'd had
to come tell these emoji whatever all
right let's take a look um why is this
not uh beyond the doctor character which
I don't think I need I want to just look
up the character um can somebody look
this up let's see come on there's got to
be a
code charts
Oh No
come now where is it
Oh help I want to just go find my hex
code okay five six eight nine six up
somebody on our streamers is faster to
this some
Colonel era blocks will still show the
character well okay um let's try five
six 208
okay let's it's got to be in hex um
on zcz sneak
db9 zero
what is this
what is this what's going on so this
normalization is leading to something
hi surrogate area so this is really
weird whatever is going on here so how
do we get to this we got to this by
doing
a text normalized NFD of 1 million
okay so something is very weird here
I think this is not our bug I think this
is some kind of unicode weirdness
okay let's see if we if we go to
gosh this slow typing and the twelve
point one that I have here is really
annoying let's try this F four two four
zero
what is that
you f zero zero zero
supplementary
you seria okay well it got totally
confused and I would argue this Polly a
bug in the NF t in there NF decode um
oh wow the pink box will actually show
the emoji character when has not been
evaluated that's even Wilder that's
really wild so if I start a new version
it should be able to do that
um
no it's not really
to a sex this is this is it's it's it's
correct about that
I'm very weird okay let's come back to
yeah I agree with Karla our live stream
the text text normalized is much more
like a text function like text sentences
and so on I think this should be
character normalize so I proposed RiRi
nameless and I think then we should um
go ahead and redo some of what it does
here so let's go ahead and do the rename
um see if a handy rename it we should
wait to see how much extra me extra form
we want to add we're not gonna add any
extra forms what other forms we think of
adding hello I mean we could go far you
know whispers iterate with like why
we've already got transliterate yeah
yeah I mean we already have removed
their critique and when we shouldn't put
that in here I don't think we should
have that in here I think this is purely
a character normalizer
that's doing these very specific
character normalizations okay so we
removed the equity class lowercase
uppercase I think so okay then it could
even be yeah yeah character normalize
yeah all Unicode normalize or something
I don't think it should be unicode
normalize it's some herbs because I
think that um we're not naming other
things you know we have chosen we chose
in the early 90s to sort of standardize
our character stuff around Unicode
you
okay so but I think text Norma is an
interesting thing for the future um
normalises characters end string
according to what do they call these
things in here normalization forms
um
let's see
we can say converts the
characters in string to the specified
normalization form okay so then I think
what we should do here is just to say
explicitly um right
you
we should say that it supports a list of
strings um okay so
um
I think we just do this if you don't
disagree here
I think this becomes okay so NFC becomes
what they're calling it is
actually we want to start with an F D
canonical decomposition separate out
you
you
you
okay then
now then then the other two forms here
what is compatibility to composition
what does that mean
if you have like ages then it sort of
yeah separates them out
you
do we deal with this correctly strength
concatenation with these things yes
those are the forms like that's the
exact no no no I understand I understand
but when we were me I mean because you
know for example languages like c'mere
that have all these totally weird
diacritics you know like four different
kinds of diacritics for having many
kinds of diacritics
you
yeah I agree with sander that examples
of these forms are super useful I think
that we can give them any examples um
but let me just understand the NF KD
okay so that is a
what is this thing here
great so compatibility tries to turn it
into something more um
you
yeah I mean by the way I think um
Carl's commented seems wrong not to have
diacritic removal I I think though that
removing diacritics the point of these
things is that they're not losing
information
these things are all just recirculating
around and not that there seemed it
seems to be a unique thing let's take
this example what is this creature help
do I really have to type this one a 9 B
you
they're a zero three two three there
afterwards so let's see 1e9 oops one e9b
I see zero three two three
but that didn't compose yeah you see
that's the problem is that we're not
composing some of these things where
there are um and that's what happens in
like c'mere for example
right
see that we're not doing that correctly
and almost nobody does am I making sense
I we probably have the wrong set of
people here I mean the do you understand
what this is this is so in I don't you
have in like French and things dead keys
on typewriters maybe a 10 is too young
to be used a typewriter yeah you know
what I was very young at the time well
but you know what I mean by dead keys
right you press a key and the the it
pret types a diacritic but the carriage
does not that the yeah yeah this is like
that but in Unicode
and that's how a lot of these some
you
I mean I think um oh dear this is a bit
of a mess if I might say so I mean what
you're basically doing
which is obviously useful for
particularly machine learning type stuff
is just purely implementing these
forms
and we'll make also put them into net
encoders
yeah I understand but they're not will
they have their own NAT encoders
I'm not sure that's your home I think he
thought about that already
it may be into characters in an encoder
okay but how are you gonna put them in
it could be options well but but then
why do we have this whole function if
it's if its main use is gonna be in the
net encoder I I agree that this function
is somewhat useful but it's still oh boy
this is such a mess between the
rendering of these things which you know
as I say almost no programs get it right
for these languages with huge numbers of
weird head and feet diacritics and so on
I think I'm not even sure web browsers
get it right um okay well
let's just
this for a second
I think it's okay to call this character
normalize I think removing since that is
after all what is being it's not a kind
of concept that you usually think of and
I think remove diacritics
is a yeah I don't know I mean we could
imagine adding that to this but I think
I think it has its own separate function
um
okay so so then apparently
yeah all right
well let's just list what they say these
things are and then let's say I mean
we've got to have examples here of
actual things in these notes have actual
them okay so what we what we'll want is
a table that just goes the character and
then you know at the cross the top
yeah I mean in our world in our
documentation we don't need to have so
much have to write the character code
because you can always copy paste it
okay so what I'm imagining here is that
there's a grid oops let's just make it
here um we make a
you
says what is this alignment what is this
this oh so this was something we'll need
at some point probably but because it
was enough sure we decided to drop it
for 12.1 it's a way to keep to remember
which character corresponds to which
character in the input and output so
during the alignment between the input
set a string and output string and so
we're just here we're just like
brainstorming the possible language to
represent this alignment there's one
that is will use the same as sequence
alignment where you have you know a list
of possible things so I think if you go
a little bit upper yeah like sequence
alignment has this you know what when
when the string is in common there's no
no list but as soon as there's your
friend as a list that'll be one way
which i think is nice for the user but
not necessarily nice for a program to
handle so then we thought well I'm just
an album here so the problem here is you
want to for purposes of machine learning
you're going to normalize the string but
you always want to keep track of you
know if you're going to highlight some
part of the string in the original you
want to know where I think of text cases
yeah if you look test cases or fine
textual answer which actually points
you know if pointers to original text
well so then this function what you what
you what you're doing effectively is
you're using this function but you want
it to preserve the you know you're going
character by character you're doing this
operation but you want the output to not
be I mean in a sense if the way this
worked was I mean if if what happened
was that the original character string
um was effectively let's say was
something like um you know
was this then you would be happy if you
know if the final character since it's a
character by character transformation
right then anything that happens would
be you know if this becomes three
characters then you're still good I'm
making sense in that case yes I think in
all cases of this if based on what this
normalization is doing that's what would
always happen but you should an example
of if they're critique and letter was
separated then he would compose it no I
mean the the yes that is correct but but
you're not going to be in that situation
that is not a natural form of a string
[Music]
I see I see somebody's asked you a
question about fermions in physics model
sorry wrong discussion not talking about
that here I'm happy to talk about it but
not here though although okay you get
get this for something funny so I'm
trying to figure out what is the you
know string rewriting for example right
question is what is the continuum limit
of string rewriting
okay so you know you write rewrite a
string like you have something like you
know a B goes to be a a in any string
make sense so so the question is like in
a cellular automaton or something sort
of the continuum limit is something like
a PDE the question is what is the
continuum limit of a string rewrite
where the string rewrite is like a good
example
[Music]
something like uh you know something
like that some snow that's a trivial
string right where it's just one
character turning into two okay the
question is what's the continuum limit
of a thing like this
um and the real pun here is that um well
anyway I leave that as an exercise for
the reader somebody can figure it out
let me know I I have an idea which is
more amusing than you can possibly
imagine um the um okay let's come back
to this alright so I think this is non
stupid because I think what this is
doing is its packaging little pieces of
character of a character sequence
because I think that that the case there
is no naturally occurring character with
separated diacritic
if that happens it is a cheaper way to
represent a character like like what we
are doing with that foot diacritic thing
those aren't really separated by making
sense so if you end up with a string
where those are separated I mean they're
in any source string they better not be
separated
if they are separated you've got to do
something that's because it was an
intermediate string somewhere
I guess it makes sense we should look at
all cases but there's not one Kay I mean
we originally we thought that take some
allies might do more things no no I
understand it I'm saying it for what
you're talking about about about
alignment the obvious thing to do is to
turn a text string into something like
this then run text normalize on our
character normalize on it see what I'm
saying and you have alignment then you
know where everything is aligned yeah
and so we don't need to have any extra
arguments take normalize that's correct
so I mean just as a convention you want
to know how things line up do this
yeah that would work forward purpose I
think Karl is asking should this
function that should be an option two
characters
like character decomposition method
unfortunately not because of because of
this fact that they um
um
you
you
uncie
so Carl is pointing out that you can an
Irish who can write something which
let's see if we can paste it correctly
you
you
Wow
okay
um all right so let's see what happens
so the prediction is text normalized
here will in the NF D mode will do that
okay that's good
yeah well so cause
there's some standard transliteration
but that's a different thing from if we
take this and we say transliterate that
right there turns
to that which is fine and dandy but one
of the things that okay so a separate
thing you might need is transliteration
with mapping of where the thing came
from because none of these text
normalized functions are doing this so
far as I can tell right
well let's see compatibility
decomposition let's see what that does
on this case
you
huh okay
to do the same doctor okay I don't
understand then so there's a separate
case which is transliterate where you've
again got this question about of
alignment
right which one would have to handle now
how would that be handled because then
we'd have to have a version of
transliterate yeah with my proposal we'd
have to have a version of transliterate
that takes a take something like this
for our purpose when four-cross
deteriorate we we don't if we don't use
transliterate and I don't think we will
so I mean I know we would use it but but
not in like four four four I guess maybe
I don't see immediate use of that for
machine learning purpose at least and
generally you want to train directly on
the proper character set okay it's the
right yeah yes I think so because you
might have a transliterated text all
right what are we gonna do with
character normal eyes um I think we come
to run out of time right here but I
think first of all you need a table in
here of you know I could write the code
but I think you can do it of a bunch of
examples of the you know going across
the top NFD NFC n FK D etc you know
whatever it is a standard sequence of
characters shown what it does now we're
going to have to make some notes and you
probably need to talk to the front-end
team and others about what we're doing
with these characters where we are not
rendering correctly I'm making sense yep
I had a question do we have a default
I don't think so I don't know what it is
yet
yes yeah okay
systematically checks it four pairs of
care
to meet certain criteria okay so it's
basically aggregating on the back it's
never it's always assuming the
diacritics are put trailing a character
but the key character is a beginning
that's odd in this case here oh I see
that's a concatenation makes sense all
right let's see if we can um so if we
just list
um
you
mopes formed thee we should list it in
the order that that makes logical sense
here um
etc okay and then then give a table and
I think this is this is what we'll be
able to do here and make sure it's
referred to one removed our critics and
so on
um I think you need to ask me about this
again when you've done this and when you
can tell me how it works with net
encoder and net decoder
let's talk briefly about it again okay
all right well since and then and then
in terms of this alignment thing um I do
recommend at least showing an example of
how you can use text normal text
character normal eyes in a case like
that to where you preserve the locations
and
you know I'm trying to think um
carl is noticing that we don't support
irish and the vast majority of functions
like transliterate really trance everett
is using the romanization scheme that um
I I think transliterate has it's using
standard romanization schemes but I
think we put in several different ones
and we do a pretty good job but it would
be great to improve it Stiller there's
so we used it for our extended language
classifier yeah that we can recognize
700 languages and also transliterated
ones and and it was not I mean for at
least a long wait we tried it was not so
great like a speaker wouldn't consider
it like that okay it's kind of not our
fault because we're using a bunch of
standard romanization let's pick a word
like fish for example um that we can
translate into lots of languages okay
there we go
not as many I thought but but let's
translate try transliterating this this
should romanize every one of these and I
don't believe it will
okay so Burmese for example we have not
transliterated there and I believe that
we've been progressively adding you know
transliteration schemes for different
languages but but notice that in here
right those are little diacritics you
know those characters there that is one
of these dead key diacritic things that
has not been composited
I mean this is a mess this this you know
yeah I think some of the transliteration
was very like like it was phonetically
correct but first of all Amir was
telling me that for Farsi you wouldn't
write it like that and no one would
relax it like that is like when he reads
it it's actually phonetically correct
you know it looks like the right but
it's like we one knows for Russian there
are many different translations yeah and
people
ah you know and there been between you
know the government's mandating that
this is how it should be transliterated
and other people saying that's the wrong
form I like put Chevy chef has how many
transliterations I have no idea um um
but I mean what's surprising is cases
like this where there simply isn't any
transliteration at all
others come here with its with its wild
stuff um so the thing you see for
Burmese is also what I see for Hindi or
Bengali the two languages like I know so
it also separates it out in three which
it should not I did not exactly know
what it meant
like what the term was but yes
where was you mean if you look at Hindi
on here for example it this one's this
one's fine but like in general like if
you have those the thing that you see in
Bengali sorry the TU thing you see in
Burmese in this example it's not there
but the fish example it's not there okay
but I have seen that before
yeah well right I mean look I didn't
Hindi have have joined characters and
things exactly yeah there are join
characters with extras extra type I
don't recall we don't call it diacritics
but yes so it splits it in a way it
shouldn't so yeah I know I mean it's
really hard to render all this stuff
exactly yes um and you know the Unicode
character sequence the thing is that in
Unicode they have chosen you know in
some languages I think Korean does this
you know the the Hangul characters which
are factored in the composition of a
character are combined into single
pieces of Unicode space but in other
languages where there are composited
like you know look obviously French got
its accented characters as individual
characters but it's not self evident
that that would happen that is if there
were two you know an accent ague or
whatever it's called you know that on a
typewriter that was a separate key I
think um and not something where there
was a you know a single key wither with
an accented character and I think these
many of these languages have that
feature that they get their diacritics
by having separate characters that are
separated out in the unicode character
sequence and that's a huge mess because
um you know that means when you you know
what do you do if you ask for the
characters of the string there's a
syntactic form in which you're you know
just breaking it character by character
by the essentially multi-byte bytecode
and you know there's a choice right you
could you could use up a bunch of
Unicode space by having all
combinatorial combinations of character
and its accents or you can break it like
this and I think in a bunch of languages
it's broken and that's really hard to
deal with yes like in the language is
like most of the like Indian languages
the Sanskrit once it's broken so it's
hard yes it happens that way my general
knowledge did is that where they all are
all those scripts derived from Sanskrit
or are they in the Pentagon not all
Indian languages are derived from
Sanskrit but the ones in not Indian not
India are and some of them follow
general rules like you are saying like
like all the like what you call them
like ah II those phonetic things they
are they have to be broken like you were
saying so and breaking that is confusing
for other people who cannot read it so I
might write well I mean look it's
right-to-left languages or even another
can of worms and which we have slowly
been solving but boy is that difficult
and when you have things like a
mathematical text that reads left to
right in the middle of its yeah yeah I
think um yes when is a when is a win is
a letter not a letter okay so anyway for
app I mean and that's what basically
this character normalized thing is all
about is when is a letter not a letter
and when do you because I don't even
understand the fact that you can
decompose eeeh cute for example into an
e with a separate you know a cute
character is it's not obvious why you
would want to do that except for things
like machine learning um anyway okay
look I think we got a path forward here
for character normalise um this was
despite you know this is always what
happens when when when one predicts this
will be an extremely easy meeting that
will take only five minutes those are
the worst of them there okay all right
you there any any further issues here
that we want to talk about I think
there's a path forward here and don't
you know make a table here give
some examples of very simple things to
begin with here and let's take it from
there yep thank you
okay thanks a lot thanks to light I've
seen - okay see ya bye